The true conflict of One Punch Man is Saitama's
hopeless obsession for just another fun fight,
and his refusal to move on with his life from
that.
Saitama keeps saying that he is a hero for
fun. And yet, if there is one thing we know
about the strongest anime character ever,
it's that he doesn't have a lot of fun being
one. The guy who right from the start has
everything, that all other shounen heroes
dream of and desperately struggle for, is
suffering from a dreadful existential crisis
because how this power. But I feel like people
are surprisingly confused about the POINT
One Punch man is trying to make as a story.
It's not merely a parody of conventional shounen
and superheroes stories, or merely a story
about what it means to be a good hero. It's
also one that you will find has surprisingly
deep and profound views on life and happiness
and purpose. I learned that One Punch man
is such a masterpiece because it resonates
with you on not one, but exactly 4 levels
of meaning.
Level 1: The Parody.
Saitama is fucking hilarious. If you ever
watched any of my videos, you'll know that
I absolutely love Shounen Anime. The epic
fights, the tragic backstories, the inspiring
training arcs, the mentor guy with the white
hair who is cooler than the main character,
I love it all. The problem you might have
realized, is that this description basically
fits every single anime out there. And now
we have to things we don't want, predictability
and repetitiveness.
What made One Punch man an instant success,
even with the first episode, is that it brutally
makes fun of the typical hero. Hell, the name
of the Anime itself is a parody. One Punch
Man, a guy who defeats any enemy in an instant,
starts with the hero, where all other stories
end, at the pinnacle of the world, the strongest
of them all. And it's usually the story of
how we got there, that is so exciting. All
the blood and tears that were shed along the
way. All the obstacles and enemies that had
to be overcome and all the relationships formed
along the way. All of it to become the strongest
in order to change the world. Saitama is a
guy who used to work at a convenience store,
who then decided to become a hero for fun.
He didn't have any major motivation and the
most struggle he went through was doing a
basic daily work-out routine. Well that and
loosing his hair. But at the start of the
story, he is pretty much an average guy, who
got sort of motivated to do something great
but actually succeeded right away. And for
anyone who has suffered through the endless
training-arcs and dead loved ones dies so
I guess you get a power up scenes, this is
just a hilarious thing so see.
The true magic however, lies in the fact,
that every single character in One Punch man
is written as 100% serious. EXCEPT Saitama.
Everyone is designed to fit perfectly into
your typical anime trope. Genos, Garou and
Mumen Rider are text-book example of SHounen
protagonists, all with their own struggles
and the will to become stronger. With Bang,
you have the powerful wise mentor and pretty
much every single villain, whether minor or
major, would fit perfectly as a serious opponent
in any other story. All the characters have
cool designs, tragic pasts and complex motivations.
Everyone is drawn seriously and acts seriously.
EXCEPT Saitama. He's a pretty boring, average
dude, that is purposefully lazily and comically
drawn. And yet, since he is the strongest
of them all, he stomps on the accomplishments
of all the serious characters around him.
Take for instance Mumen rider, who's courage
in the face of an enemy that out-matches him
completely. We see him suffer and still get
up again and again, proving all the qualities
we want in our typical hero. I got so excited
for him defeating the enemy against all odds.
But, Just when you feel that hard work and
true grit will pay off Mumen rider is defeated
in a single punch and it is no other than
Saitama who arrives to effortlessly save the
day, thinking to himself [...].
The character I identify with gets defeated
in an instant, while all my hopes are undercut
by one effortless punch. It's so funny, because
I know exactly that the Anime is making fun
of my expectations.
And I realized that the same happens with
villains as well. Dr. Genus, exiled from the
scientific community he spends fifty years
trying to unlock the key to humanity’s evolution,
finally creating the powerful and mentally
unstable creature, Carnage Kabuto. A creature
fully taken in by his own power and perfection.
And yet all this buildup and characterization
for both of these antagonists is once again
undercut right away. When Kabuto gets Saitama
to revealthe secret behind his power, usually
an opportunity to depict a character’s mental
and physical development, it turns out to
be a simple workout routine. [...] The
ease with which he reached the top and defeats
all enemies, robbs all the supporting characters,
like Genos of any meaning they’ve derived
from their struggles.
The rate at which One Punch man keeps subverting
common Anime and Superhero tropes is pure
greatness. Saitama has ungodly power and the
worst or I guess best part is he didn’t
do anything special to deserve it, he isn’t
the chosen one or the underdog who sacrificed
everything to get to the top, he really is
just a twenty five year old guy who’s unsatisfied
with work. And I laugh my ass off every single
episode as a result of this. Let's go to level
2.
But first Ad Break.
Real quick, I wanna say thank you to square
space, who is the sponsor of this video, thank
you square space. If you've ever thought about
making your own personal website and actually
have that website look good, despite having
no idea how to make one, Squarespace got you
covered. They have a ton of wonderfully designed
web design templates that you can customize
to create your very own professional looking
website with no prior knowledge whatsoever,
so you can host your very own content on the
good old internet. Head over to [Squarespace.com](http://squarespace.com/)
to try it out, and once you’re ready to
launch, us my link in the description below
to get 10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain.
Level 2: The social critique.
Shounen is predictable, obsession corrupts
and life without a challenge is pointless.
Once I started to dig a little bit deeper
into the comedic surface of One Punch man,
I quickly discovered that many aspects of
the Anime are quite critical of the current
state of shounen anime, the concept of superheroes
and the societies these stories take place
in.
The first and most obvious message I found
is once again directly connected to the premise
of the story. Saitama is a man who has obtained
absolute power. He is the strongest and able
to defeat one end-boss level monster after
the next. Something every other Hero dedicates
his entire being towards. And yet, at the
end of it all, he is as dissatisfied as he
was working a regular job. Life is dull without
a challenge. When there are no stakes and
no consequences to fear for anything we do,
life becomes less enjoyable. Beginning the
story as a disillusioned young man with a
full head of hair searching for a job in business,
he discovers a passion for hero work that,
for the first time in his life, lights a fire
in his eyes. But three years later, the thrill
is gone, along with this his trademark anime
hair and he has gained the power to end any
fight in just one punch. Even though Saitama
is a really nice guy, he has fallen prey to
his own desires and expectations. After all,
his desire to become a hero in the first place
was because he thought it was fun, finally
he could be good at. Even though he usually
does the morally right thing, he doesn't fight
to safe others, but for his own pleasure.
And since he is already the strongest, this
obsession with having a good fight, leaves
him eternal dissatisfied. That is the true
conflict in One Punch Man.
It's a central theme of the story. Becoming
obsessed with the goal of becoming stronger,
which typically sets our hero apart from the
rest and allows him to grow, is explored through
a more human and realistic lens here.
Take a moment to appreciate that the most
common way normal people turn into Monsters
in this world is by succumbing to their obsessions:
Crablante, for example, was so obsessed with
eating crabs that he turned into one. Phoenix
Man was obsessed with grief and with his role
in his cancelled TV show, so much that he
merged with his bird costume. Genos and turns
less and less human with every upgrade he
gets. Just as Garou becomes more and more
Monster, the harder he pushes. All the way
to Amai Mask, who is consumed by his desire
to be beautiful. I got the strong feeling,
that the lines between Humans and monsters
get more and more blurred as the story unfolds.
So, once again subverting typical Anime tropes,
the main theme is not about not giving up.
In fact, the story has made it clear that
there are times when a person should give
up. It's about staying human.
That insight really hit home for me when I
rewatched the last episode of season one.
Boros' backstory is actually the exact same
as Saitamas. He is an invincible being that
got so obsessed with a good fight, that he
started eradicating planets in order to find
strong opponents. He is a mirror for Saitama's
fault. A warning for what our bald hero might
become, should he find no way to leave his
obsession behind.
On a larger scale, I also found that One Punch
man also criticizes the concepts of superhero
societies in general. How do creators keep
on upping the stakes and make it interesting
for fans who’ve already seen it all? Is
there a point where it all starts to feel
recycled? In the world of One Punch man, this
is expressed in form of the Hero association,
who's creation was actually sparked by Saitama
when he saved the little kid form the crab.
As it turns out daddy had a lot of money.
However, since Saitama lives outside the system,
we get to experience it for the first time
side by side with him. I found that the Hero
Association's ranking system and the egos
and internal strife within it are an interesting
take on the idea of superheroes as famous
celebrities. Power doesn't corrupt, it reveals
who you were all along.
This show was actually pretty serious in its
undertone and mercilessly deconstructs some
of the issues often ignored in Anime.
Level 3: The life lesson.
Saitama teaches you what actually matters
in life. You may or may not believe me, but
the true message behind One punch man actually
goes even deeper. Far from being a pure comedy
show or simply criticizing the status quo
in anime, One has intentionally planned his
story to be the real deal right from the start.
The world of One Punch man with its enormous
cities that are harassed by cataclysmic monsters
every other day, is built specifically for
Saitama to work as the protagonist. A guy
who punches big and strong things on a daily
basis. That makes it even more impressive
than to me, how rich and real this world starts
to feel a few episodes into the story. I talked
about all characters but Saitama being written
completely seiriously. But that does not only
result in a comedic effect, it also makes
these people feel real and relatable and we
have a lot of fantastic character arcs for
people like Genos, Garo or Sonic.
Their contrast to Saitama is not only to be
funny, they contrast him to shine light on
the true point of One Punch man as a story.
Saitama is purposefully created as the exact
opposite of an anime protagonist. Drawing
him as simply as he is has the really fascinating
effect, that we have to judge him not by his
appearance, but by his actions and personality.
No epic hair and no badass costume. Saitama
is so special as a main character because
people love him for just himself.
Wanting to be the strongest, is something
that only very few people relate to. Worrying
about money, what to have for dinner and procrastinating
stuff on the other hand: Relatable. Watching
TV and playing video games on a Tuesday morning?
Also Extremely Relatable.
Saitama is easy to love as a character because
power reveals who someone is at heart. And
Saitama is just this nice, but kind of clueless
dude in his 20s. And it's no big surprise
I think that this is attractive.
Most importantly however, Saitama's big flaw
as a character might be the most relatable
thing of them all. He is obsessed with the
thought that being a strong hero will make
him happy. Will fulfill him. And yet once
he gets what he wants, it doesn't. The real
journey of Saitama is not to find someone
that he can have a real fight with. Once that's
over it would be just straight back to dissatisfaction.
It's Saitama realizing that he needs to move
on from his fantasy and actually becoming
a great hero character-wise. Finding happiness
in the moment by spending time with people
like Genos and finding purpose in his ability
to protect humanity and inspire others. It
is actually King, who summarizes the goal
of One punch man perfectly: ["You are the
most powerful hero of all, BUT you are NOT
the best hero, aspire to be one."]. Here is
another video for you to watch!